cette vieille dame de 85 ans a toujours
vécu ici et gardent les traces d'un
passé douloureux
c'était sous domination tibétaine dans
les années 40
c'était quand j'étais jeune les seniors
tibétains venait ici prendre les femmes
pour en faire des esclaves ils nous
capturé par dizaines celles qui comme
moi ne sont pas partis ont toutes été
tatoué au visage pour que nous puissions
jamais nous marier ici les vieilles sont
toutes marquées et celle enlevée par les
tibétains ne sont jamais revenus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les rapports dominants
dominés ont changé et les femmes de la
vallée ne craignent plus les tibétains
dont les premiers villages ne sont qu'à
quelques kilomètres d'ici
[Musique]
installé sur les hauts plateaux
montagneux ce monastère abrite une
dizaine de moines
ensemble ils partagent leur temps entre
prières et méditation
[Musique]
à 22 ans zhang est le plus jeune d'entre
eux sa mission convertir les habitants
de la vallée au bouddhisme chez les
habitants de la vallée
il y à une recrudescence pour le culte
de bouddha cindy retrouve depuis que je
m'occupe du village il y a un intérêt
beaucoup plus fort pour la religion
c'est une bénédiction pour le monastère
depuis que le tibet a été annexé par la
chine à la fin des années 40
les tibétains sont sous haute
surveillance surtout les moines accusé
par le gouvernement chinois d'entretenir
la volonté d'indépendance de leur peuple
et de les pousser à la révolte
allez encore un peu recul je suis assez
près là ça va c'est pour cette raison
que le gouvernement chinois a fait
détruire beaucoup de temples et jeté en
prison les moindres rebelles alors la
scène qui se déroule ce matin là tient
un peu du miracle en chine
les chinois converti au bouddhisme par
zhang sont venus prêter main forte à la
reconstruction du temple
ils prennent un risque à se montrer avec
le moine mais ils l'assument par
conviction leur paye quelques prières et
un peu d'alcool je ne les ai pas je leur
donne de la bière en échange vous savez
ils sont croyants ils font ça pour le
bouddhisme
ce sont des fidèles et on n'a jamais eu
d'incident car nous prions beaucoup
monastère pour éviter ça
le camion rempli zhang tiens quand même
à jeter lui même la dernière pierre ou
là elle est lourde
allez bon on va y aller mais tu crois
vraiment qu'il va pouvoir remonter au
village ton vieux camion mais bien sûr
lemoine a raison de s'inquiéter
même s'il affiche peu de kilomètres au
compteur ce camion est une antiquité et
son moteur réclament souvent de petits
réglages
il
le problème c'est que la route est
vallonné le camion souffrent côte alors
il faut prendre soin du moteur sentir le
bon moment pour changer les vitesses et
surtout être dans le bon régime
c'est pas simple ici on apprend par soi
même on conduit à l'instinct
[Musique]
alors pour soulager le moteur au maximum
ce chauffeur à une technique des plus
risquées dans les descentes ses roues
libres
et à fond sur le frein
voilà le secret
mais en bas de la pente il va lui
falloir une bonne dose de patience pour
remonter la peau car le camion peine à
grimper et la vitesse tombe sous les 10
km
mais surtout le moteur frise la
surchauffe alors cette fois l'astuce
réside dans ce petit robinet bricoler
sous le siège
tu vois ce petit robinet d'eau il sert à
refroidir le moteur grâce un bidon
placée sur le toit
si t'as pas ça tu casses et arrive
jamais
[Musique]
c'est bon je peux reculer wave asie
c'est tout droit
avec ce dernier chargement les travaux
de la nouvelle pagode vont enfin pouvoir
commencer
zhang espère que les autorités chinoises
le laisseront agrandir son monastère
afin qu'ils puissent y accueillir une
trentaine de moines mais au tibet au
moindre signe de révolte le gouvernement
fait fermer la plupart des temples et
expulse les moines
oh